welcome to this video in terms of us a
new Mariano's okay once you form yeah I
already should learn something good
against that it's really forgetting that
all the time that already should think
of a good line against it okay I decided
to go with e5 I kind of keep it simple
approach just plain natural move move I
probably should have taken on c3m okay
that not that is a huge problem but I
would have liked to settle him with the
doubled pawns
Jim it's d5 a move or is this too too
loose maybe md5 yeah that looks and
looks a little bit much after him cd5
yeah I don't like my position very much
that's not the kind of thing I'm I want
to play I should have taken on c3
earlier then you at least have a clear
target yeah form for attack done the
double pawns ok so he loves that which
it's not a problem why anything he's
threatening 95 now okay I can play I
can't just take I can make me do this
yam yeah let me let me play c6 possibly
allowing me to retreat the bishop and I
don't give it up now and here yeah this
is okay this is probably an ok position
I can play let's say d6 be should be
seven root d8 Bishop see aid and go from
there this kind of setup should be okay
pretty pretty solid ok might go for 94
but that's not really an issue yeah
looks like a box in bishop but really
not not much else I can do I cannot put
it on c5 or anything so I have to be
content with that but it's not so bad
queen e 5 yeah needs to be done ok
India Knight f3 o NH 500k neta 3 is not
an issue f4 queen is 75 maybe oh yeah I
should have paid more attention to that
one ok that's not good he's pushing it
all the way there f5 f6 I have 95 the
offices this is some very useful to have
ok so i get one moment to play something
active let's do this year I have to to
get some kind of central play ok so he's
attacking this ok that's not a huge
problem I can take ok where I takes you
for Bishop takes the dis directly
hanging ok retreat that
95 him okay well that's not so bad I I
doubt that this is a huge problem here
can my books are now decently placed and
I'm well centralized so this this must
be okay let's see um f6f 636 not so easy
to do and also is it play oh ok let's
maybe gain a tempo here he cannot really
trade queens I mean we can but this is
not how not troubling me and I can go
from them also possibly there are
sacrifices on e3 for further for the
pins so f 6m I can just play g6 that's
not a problem at all I think so look you
five maybe yeah piling up on the upon
down to two minutes but okay I'm not far
behind clockwise Knight f3 i will take
the take the f pawn okay
okay eight Bishop c5 this kind of thing
I might at least I'm able to make some
play some moves quickly here yeah before
I was just thinking about that one that
this might be an idea I wonder if I
should just play a five and still fight
for the c5 square or Bishop is seven
there should be seven for Bishop g5 is
also possible the rook or Bishop f6 now
the slot bed it's not bad the bishop
however have to be a bit a bit careful
with the rookie only five it has its
kind of on its own a5 is also move i
would love to play but he could just you
couldn't he could just take it last move
so
g5 on ok let's go to g 5 f-5 is also
hanging
yeah don't know but what is he doing now
Brooke ever ugh c3 is there even
something more forceful than now ad for
some possible move then I can just take
it of course sorry I can just take it
yeah again I can just take it the
question is with what actually actually
um yeah there is possibly Queen Queen to
Queen takes d5 at the end but I'm not
checkmated here right check so I can
grab this stuff will be to basically
just has this check on f 70 and King g8
nothing special happening here
okay hindmarsh so here I can just go
rookie 7i guess or I can kinda take
check check take a 2 and the rook is
pinned at the moment yeah this is the
easiest way to play it really get the
Queen off of this place of this is the
square justice that's easiest I think
can take with the king white resigns
yeah surprised I mean no I think
initially initially am i'm a bit
struggling here maybe computers is not
agreeing its assets it's about equal i
wasn't sure really White's active pieces
in the center look look a bit scary and
I had I hadn't really appreciated app
for that that correctly added this was
hitting so so quickly ok d5 yeah this is
I really wanted to counter play this
sort of why I played it quite quickly
it's not approved by the computer okay
well zero point three years nothing
special for white but still f5 year and
now takes takes takes this is the
computer main line so that wasn't so
terribly bad capture yeah after the
capture I'm better yeah this is what I
suspected really this this cintas looks
nice Bishop e7 Bishop g5 immediately is
stronger yeah okay I had this idea only
later I was led I mean I was happy about
this move it wins the tempo in a way and
Tim and now I went every key five-year
Bishop e7 was again a bit stronger and
here f6 is the computer suggestion so
to g6 Thea queen back and just a slight
edge from black and this looks this
looks a little bit more dangerous in any
case yeah with the pawn here so that's
yeah if I'm completely now this can
happen and if the diagonal opens okay
but here no I keep missing Bishop e7
only now I saw it so I saw this idea or
how strong it was here here here he is
tall was he simply cannot cover that
anymore check and takes yeah I actually
I saw that but I thought what i did was
simpler hear this I can take but I
wasn't completely sure if but he hasn't
even it doesn't even have a check ride
yeah I wasn't you know here I was
thinking okay probably I'm checkmating
him but hmm if I'm not it's it's a bad
it's bad so I just put it back and I'm
winning here without any any calculation
this is a bit lazy chest probably but
but completely completely sufficient
okay hope you enjoyed that thanks for
watching